LEVERAGING FOR POSITION.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINS US FROM THE
NORTH ONE WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
LATEST TAKE ON THE SUBJECT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH ON THE
SUBJECT SINCE NORTH KOREA
STARTED GOING SQUISHY ON THE
IDEA OF THE SUBJECT, BUT TODAY
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN A CHATTY
MOOD AND STILL OPTIMISTIC.
IN THE OVAL OFFICE WITH NATO
SECRETARY GENERAL TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP REVEALED THAT,
DESPITE INTEMPERATE LANGUAGE
FROM NORTH KOREA IN RECENT DAYS,
HIS JUNE SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN
APPEARS TO BE STILL BE ON TRACK.
>> President Trump: NOTHING
HAS CHANGED ON NORTH KOREA THAT
WE KNOW OF.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN TOLD ANYTHING,
AND IF IT DOES, THAT'S FINE.
IF IT DOESN'T, I THINK WE WILL
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL MEETING.
>> Reporter: AND STATEMENTS
MADE EARLIER THIS WEEK, THEY
SINGLED OUT COMMENTS FROM JOHN
BOLTON WHO DESCRIBED IT TO EACH
CHRIS WALLACE WHAT HE SAID WAS A
WHITE HOUSE'S VISION FOR
NORTH KOREAN DISARMAMENT.
>> WE HAVE ARE VERY MUCH IN MIND
THE LIBYA MODEL FROM 2003-2004.
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY DIFFERENCES,
THE LIBYAN PROGRAM WAS MUCH
SMALLER, BUT THAT WAS BASICALLY
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE MADE.
AN >> Reporter: EIGHT HE WAS
QUICK TO REMIND THE WORLD THAT
THE U.S. TURNED ON QADDAFI.
THE U.S. THREATENED TO OVERTHROW
QADDAFI WHO WAS LATER MURDERED
IN THE STREETS BY AN ANGRY MOB.
WITH THE NATIONAL SECURITY AT
ADVISOR LOOKING ON,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWO DAYS OF THE
MODEL FOR NORTH KOREAN
DISARMAMENT WILL BE MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN LIBYA.
>> President Trump: THE MODEL
ISN'T WHAT WE HAVE AT ALL WHEN
WE THINK OF NORTH KOREA.
IN LIBYA, WE DECIMATED THAT
COUNTRY.
WE NEVER SAID TO QADDAFI, WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE YOU PROTECTION, WE
WILL GIVE YOU MILITARY STRENGTH.
>> Reporter: THE PRESIDENT
INDICATED THAT IN RETURN FOR
DISMANTLING HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM,
CAN LOOK AT GUARANTY'S.
ECONOMIC, SECURITY AND
POLITICAL.
>> President Trump: HE WOULD
BE RUNNING HIS COUNTRY, HIS
COUNTRY WOULD BE VERY RICH.
>> WHAT SECURITY GUARANTEES ARE
YOU WILLING TO GIVE?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
WILLING TO DO A LOT AND HE'S
WILLING TO DO A LOT, ALSO.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP ASSUMING WE HAVE
THE MEETING AND SOMETHING COMES
OF IT.
HE WILL GET PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
VERY STRONG.
>> Reporter: BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO WARNED THAT
THE IT COULD HAPPEN.
A DEAL, I THINK KIM JONG UN WILL
BE VERY, VERY HAPPY.
>> Reporter: PRESENT HAS
TALKED ABOUT WANTING TO REDUCE
THE SIZE OF THE U.S. PROTECTION
FORCE IN SOUTH KOREA COME DOWN
FROM THE CURRENT 28,500 TROOPS.
NORTH KOREA HAS LONG DEMANDED
THAT THE U.S. REMOVE TROOPS FROM
SOUTH KOREA.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD NOT
SAY IF THAT WAS ON THE TABLE.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT, I WILL
SAY THAT HE WILL HAVE PRETTY
ADEQUATE PROTECTION AND WE WILL
SEE HOW IT ALL TURNS OUT.
I THINK THIS, THE BEST THING HE
COULD EVER DO IS TO MAKE A DEAL.
>> Bret: IN HIS MEETINGS WITH
THE NATO SECRETARY GENERAL TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN HOW HE
IS PREPARED TO TREAT NORTH KOREA
AND HOW HE MAY TREAT IRAN GOING
FORWARD, SAYING THAT ANY NEW